Novel distributed multimedia applications tend to
be sensor-based. And these sensors can be
simple sensors, like temperature sensors and
humidity sensors, or more interesting and complex
sensors, like cameras and microphones and radars and so on. And these sensors
are distributed, which means that you have to access them via the internet.
And what we want to do with these sensor streams is live-stream analysis,
and often, often such applications are
also called situation awareness applications. Where what
we are doing is we are gathering sensor data in order to analyze in
real time what is happening in the environment and take appropriate decisions.
So such situation awareness applications exhibit a
control loop going from sensing, prioritizing the sense
data to figure out what are important.
For instance, if there are lots of cameras
and there is no action in front
of some cameras, some cameras are more interesting
than others. That is the prioritization step,
of figuring out what sensors are interesting and
then devoting more computational resources to analyze the camera streams
or other sensor streams and as a result of that, taking some actions. And this
might involve actuating other sensors, actuating
triggers, actuating other software entities, or even
humans, to intervene in terms of what actions were needed to be taken.
And part of this control loop may also
be feedback to the sensors themselves to re-target them.
For example, there may be a camera that you
may want to point in a different direction. And
there are cameras like pan, tilt, zoom cameras,
which you may want to control depending on what
you are observing in the environment. And such a
control loop characterization of situation awareness applications can be
applied to a lot of
emerging distributed multimedia sensor-based, applications such
as traffic analysis, emergency response, disaster
recovery, robotics, acid tracking and so
on and all such applications are computationally intensive. And because they
are dealing with real live streams coming from the sensors, they have real-time
properties, which means that there is a need to shrink the
latency from sensing to actuation, so that we can take tiny
actions based on the sensed data. Since they're computationally intensive, we
need horsepower to run these
large-scale novel multimedia distributed sensor-based applications.
And so computational engines such as the clusters and the clouds may be deployed
in order to cater to the needs
of these large scale, sensor-based distributed applications.